hey youtubers is Charlie and we are
within the 7 day window for series 8
we're almost there so I recently did a
starter guide in case you'd never watch
Doctor Who before that mostly included
episodes from new Doctor Who but the BBC
was really nice and suggested that I do
one for classic ooh so that's what this
video is gonna be it's just a starter
guide so if you are really passionate
about classic ooh feel free to leave
your own recommendations in the comments
and I'll also be including streaming
links for everything on tumblr so
there'll be a link for that in the
description if you're just finding me
for the first time though I do weekly
Doctor Who videos I'm gonna be doing a
whole bunch of stuff for each of the
episodes this series I'm even doing a
weekly giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so super quick
classic who explainer as a series doctor
who's been around for over 50 years it
started back in the 1960s and ran till
it was cancelled in the mid to late 90s
eventually Russell T Davies swooped in
and helped the BBC reboot it in 2005 so
everything before the reboot is referred
to as classic Doctor Who so whenever
you're searching for it on the web for
episodes you have to search classic
Doctor Who otherwise it'll return its
search results for the new series they
also had this weird numbering thing
where classic who episodes are listed by
season and the new reboot are listed by
a series so season and series are two
different things right now on Hulu
there's about four hundred and thirteen
episodes of classic Doctor Who I think
it's Hulu Plus actually that is a
shitload of TV that is barely half of it
though a lot of the older episodes are
missing as of right now in total there
are 800 episodes including all the new
reboot stuff one of the big questions
obviously is do I have to watch
everything short answer no but watching
classic ooh will give you more context
for the way Peter Capaldi's episodes
will play out visually and thematically
because I get the sense that Peter
Capaldi's doctor in terms of tone just
links closest to the third and fourth
Doctor I'm gonna start with those
episodes in general though it's fun to
just go back and watch the first
appearance of a lot of big characters
monsters villains so there's a lot of
things that I don't include in my list
that are also important but I'll try and
include in my tumblr link roundup so
let's start with the third doctor he was
Peter Capaldi's introduction to the
series he even got to go on set and meet
him one time I'm gonna try and limit
this to it just a couple episodes per
doctor but first off there's spearhead
from space it's the first story to
feature the third doctor in his own
episode a lot of times when a doctor
regenerated you
see the new doctor but technically that
was during a finale spearhead from space
was just the first episode of a new
series when you search for it on Hulu
its season 7 episodes one through four
those are four separate 25-minute
episodes so it was a big story the way
classic whose stories organized were a
little bit different from the way they
do it right now they'd have like a story
that would cross over four episodes like
for 25 minute episodes spirited from
space is famous for several reasons of
course it's the first appearance of the
third doctor Jon Pertwee it was the
first Doctor Who episode to be broadcast
in color and it's considered the
beginning of the unit years just a
period of time where unit as a group was
a big part of the stories unit for those
that don't remember stands for unified
intelligence task force remember they
were a big part of the 50th anniversary
during classic ooh the big unit
character was Brigadier
lethbridge-stewart on the reboot his
daughter Kate is head of unit so that's
the person that you saw in the 50th
anniversary if you watch that episode
spearhead from space is also really
interesting because it's the beginning
of this arc where the doctor has been
exiled to Earth by the Time Lords I
guess that's what you get when you
meddle with time and space too much the
main villains were the Autons these
creepy mannequin looking replicants the
episode is a good example of a really
scary creepy story that also has a lot
of humor
which is what people are saying
Capaldi's run is gonna be like like
classic horror with comedy there's also
a lot of Time Lord biology explaining
the episode so if you ever wanted a
course on Time Lord biology this would
be the episode for that then we move on
to the first appearance of the master in
terror of the Autons the Roger Delgado
master that was season 8 episodes one
through four this is the beginning of
the third doctor's second series I know
they used the Autons in the previous
series opener but the storyline
introduced us to Doctor Who's greatest
villain and from a production standpoint
it was a bit of a reboot of the third
doctor's run they just brought in new
companions new uniforms for the unit
characters and new standing sets most of
the time nowadays whenever people talk
about big changes during a doctor's run
it's new doctor outfits new TARDIS
consoles and new companions if you
watched the 2012 Christmas special with
Matt Smith they did all three of those
new TARDIS design new doctor costume and
new companion that Clara was kind of a
companion technically Clara Oswald the
companion in series 8 is different from
Clara Oswin Oswald the almost companion
side note I'm actually gonna address the
rumors about Jenna Coleman leaving
during the Christmas special
this year after my classic coup
recommendations so moving along now to
the Damon's another great master episode
it's season 8 episodes 21 through 25
it's the last story of season 8
basically it invokes a devil like
character doctor who has always done a
lot of cool versions of devil like
characters and I'm a big fan of
supernatural stories this episode just
does a really good job of addressing the
issue of the devil as a concept that is
just differentiating really powerful
supernatural beings from religious
labels like devil and God for any Marvel
fans this is actually the kind of story
you might find in a Doctor Strange comic
I always feel like Doctor Who tackling
mythology is a lot of fun so I'm looking
forward to it in series 8 hopefully they
do a lot of stories like that
moving along my final third Doctor
recommendation is the time warrior that
season 11 episodes 1 through 4 this was
the introduction of Sarah Jane Smith
probably the most famous of all of
Doctor Who companions she got her own
spin-off siliceous agreed she's probably
the most famous she's like the Tom Baker
of companions which is funny because she
was also Tom Baker's companion
interesting bit of trivia this is the
first episode to refer to the Time Lords
home planet as Gallifrey I have no idea
why they waited till the 3rd doctor's
run to officially name the planet is
Gallifrey but that's just how it
happened the episode itself is set in
medieval times and since Capaldi has the
Robin Hood robots of Sherwood episode it
only seems appropriate to watch Time
warrior I'll be really interested to see
if there's any direct references to time
warrior in robots of Sherwood but be
sure to watch both episodes and try and
find any the other big things that
happen during the episode where the Time
Lords lift the doctors exile from
Gallifrey and we meet the Sontarans for
the first time remember Strax is a
Sontaran so this is what his race looked
like during classic ooh so now let's
jump forward to the fourth doctor's
episodes Tom Baker Peter Capaldi
actually famously is sent in fan art and
fans scripts to the Doctor Who offices
during these years I think he was about
15 years old when he did it somebody
asked him on the press tour last week
about it and he said he was a little bit
embarrassed by the stuff that his 15
year old self wrote so I think that just
means he won't be doing any public
readings of those childhood fanfiction
scripts but we can always hope because I
think that'd be pretty awesome raise
your hands if you would like to see
Peter Capaldi fan scripts on a DVD
release the fourth doctor's run gets
referenced a lot just because
internationally it was the most popular
in terms of audience size it was a
period of time when Doctor Who's pop
he exploded more than ever Tom Baker was
also real lucky and got to keep Sarah
Jane as a companion for three seasons a
lot of times new companions don't last
very long after a new doctor comes on
you can consider planet of the spiders
or robot his first story Tom Baker's
four story planet of the spiders was
technically the third doctor's finale so
robot season 12 episodes one through
four was the fourth doctor's first
official story so that might be a good
place to start unless you want a really
creepy spider story then watch the
season 11 finale there are so many
important Tom Baker episodes but I feel
like Genesis of the Daleks is also a
really good place to start its season 12
episodes 11 through 16 it's a six-part
story we learned all about where the
Daleks come from and Davros who is like
the dr. Frankenstein to the Dalek
monster the Khaled mutants are still
some of the most horrific creatures that
dr. who has ever done Genesis in general
is just a really good story about the
dangers of mutually assured destruction
surprise surprise it was produced during
the mid-70s when the Cold War was still
escalating between the Soviet Union and
NATO countries you would be hard-pressed
to find a science fiction series during
that era that did not deal with nuclear
war in some way so moving along there's
pyramids of Mars very cool Egyptian
mythology episode season 13 episodes 9
through 12 it introduced zoo tech you
know very powerful villain included in
this pic mostly because Peter Capaldi
has an episode titled mummy on the
Orient Express I'm not expecting a ton
of references in the new story it's the
one that Fox's is starring in she'll
actually be performing a song in the
episode which kind of reminds me of
Kylie Minogue starring in voyage of the
Damned the 2007 Christmas special that's
actually an interesting fun fact they've
actually been a lot of real-life
celebrities that have starred in Doctor
Who over the years like big celebrities
so moving along there's brain of Morbius
it's season 13 episodes 18 through 21
for some reason it's not on Hulu but it
is on dailymotion so I'll have a master
tumblr post with links to all the
episodes so you can watch them on your
computer if you want you don't have to
go hunting for them brain of Morbius is
just really cool because the doctor has
this mental battle like Matt Smith had
and nightmare and silver if you remember
during that sequence all the faces of
the previous doctors flashed on the
screen during the scene in brain of
Morbius a picture of a young version of
the first doctor flashes up so you get
to see what the first doctor looked like
as a young man it's just a nice piece of
history
so next moving along to deadly assassin
a really awesome gallop
story that season 14 episodes 9 through
12 I think it's the only time he visited
gaol free without a companion but it's
really important because it established
the Time Lords rule of regeneration the
rule of 12 I know everyone was a little
bit confused with what went down during
the Christmas special and Matt Smith's
getting his regeneration cycle rebooted
deadly assassin is where that Canon was
established it also features the first
appearance of the Peter Pratt master who
tries to hijack a new cycle over
generations because Roger Delgado the
previous version of the master died in a
real-life car accident they had to
replace the actor so as a way to explain
the change they just used the same way
that they explain different doctors they
basically just started presenting the
master as a Time Lord who were generated
himself so his appearance would continue
to change through the years and there's
also a lot of cool doctor hoop concepts
that show up at the eye of harmony and
the seal of Rassilon so next moving on
to lakopolous that's basically the
fourth doctor's final episode it's
season 18 episodes 25 through 28 I'm
pretty sure it's not on Hulu so I'll
also include some alternate streaming
links on that tumblr post that I'm
making so this episode isn't quite as
much fun as a lot of the other Tom Baker
episodes but I still feel like it's very
important it was the first story to
feature the Anthony Ainley version of
the master and it was the fourth
doctor's regeneration into the fifth
doctor Peter Davison in real life David
Tennant the 10th doctor married Peter
Davison's real-life daughter Georgia
Moffett making the fifth doctor the
father-in-law of the 10th doctor just
some nice Doctor Who trivia and of
course Georgia herself went out to play
Jenny the doctor's future daughter in
the Canon of the series very meta very
cool I just love the way Doctor Who
bends in on itself there's a billion
other really important episodes but
since I don't want this to turn into an
hour-long video I'm just gonna include
the essentials from the other doctors in
my tumblr post with the streaming links
but if you are a huge fan of classic
Doctor Who feel free to leave your
recommendations in the comments below
there's a ton of other episodes that I
didn't list I'm not gonna do a Q&A for
this just because today is a game of
Thrones day 2 but I will be doing more
bonus videos over the course of this
week since we are within that seven day
window so in case you haven't seen it
yet Doctor Who series 8 episode 1 airs
at 7:50 p.m. UK time on BBC one
obviously it's different for
international countries for those of us
that don't live in the UK so if you're
not sure when it airs just check your
local listings the episode is 80 minutes
so be sure to adjust your DVR
accordingly if you need to and
if you don't have a TV subscription or
if you stream everything the episode
will be in the BBC iPlayer right after
it airs if you're not in the UK you
might have to use a workaround to use
the iPlayer but I'll try to add
instructions for that in my tumblr post
now just to address the rumor of Jenna
Coleman leaving so what happened is is
the mirror is reporting that Clara is
gonna end her run as a companion in this
year's Christmas special it's not
confirmed and the BBC is refusing to
comment so I'll just say that it's a
rumor I can't confirm it Capaldi is
supposed to be staying on for series 9
supposedly he's already signed along
with Steven Moffat it's Coleman that has
not made any official statements as to
whether she's staying or going so we'll
just have to wait and see about that my
next Doctor Who videos gonna be my
favorite catchphrases
everyone's wondering what Capaldi's is
gonna be so far the funniest theory I've
seen has been kidneys and just to
explain the weekly giveaway in case you
haven't seen any of my other giveaway
videos so what it is is I just do a
weekly Doctor Who giveaway all you have
to do to participate or to enter that is
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so it includes review
videos and bonus videos so for instance
right now a giveaway is starting so just
leave a comment if you're a subscriber
and I'll announce the winner the next
time I post a bonus video
congratulations to this week's winner
Persian monkey Sidious always be sure to
time travel with a banana
it's an Amazon gift card I'll message
you on your channel for details for
those that are asking I am working on a
Game of Thrones video for tonight I
still do my weekly Game of Thrones
videos while you're waiting for that you
can click here to get my last dark blue
trailer video I list all 12 episodes in
series 8 not the Christmas special
that's gonna be the 13th and click here
for my starter guide for the reboot
episodes thank you so much for watching
remember 6 days so let's all just give
each other a high-five right here
you